but everything you do whether that be
office space uh whether it be uh you
know Beavis and Butthead or any it has
some sort of lasting like it's not just
a show and and do you realize how people
are touched by the stuff that you do and
how affected they are
I hope so I mean like even little
moments let me no no I want to share
with you here's here's a clip from
Silicon Valley tell me what you remember
about this oh this was one yeah this was
watch this here's a here's a clip can
you hear me yeah it's just it's sort of
fading hello hello
oh I'm hearing you it's just the images
Nelson shut up for a second if you can
hear me make a gesture is it do you I
hear you is this I have no idea what
you're saying Nelson Nelson Nelson can
you help me please okay so that we can
we can cut him did you remember that oh
yeah tell me very well well we learned
about that we were writing
we were in The Writer's room and we had
a whole thing that we thought was super
funny before this
and with one of those they have those
things like a Segway with an iPad on top
where you can be
and like different doctors use it yeah
and you had a whole thing with that that
we thought was so funny and then we
someone pointed out that's already been
done on um
uh what's the the geek the
Chuck Lori Two and a Half Men two not
two and a half minutes Theory uh yeah uh
Theory Big Bang Theory Big Bang and and
it's like okay well we've got to come up
with something else and and
this this was uh this is what replaced
it but I uh my frustration with
technology I I love doing this show to
just put it out there I
I just really like having worked and
because I worked my second engineering
job was in Silicon Valley and I I have
like a love hate thing with technology
and that's all well it's so funny okay
that's a hate part of it so that was for
those that are just listening and not
watching that was a scene where you had
a hologram machine right yeah super
expensive which which exists like okay
yeah yeah so but but so there was a guy
that I know named David Nussbaum who is
a big do you know who he is
I know I thought for a second you're
talking about the actor who plays the
guy at the end they're not okay no I
know the actors but I'm sorry there's a
guy that I know personally that's named
David Nussbaum who is a huge Mike Judge
fan and was watching every episode of
Silicon Valley and watch this and he
laughs and he laughs at everything and
thinks this is the best and then sees
that scene of the beam and change the
path of his life really yeah he went
that's the best [ __ ] idea this is
gonna revolutionize the world and then
I'll show you his drawings and what he's
done put up his drawings this is David
nussbaum's drawing he saw that machine
he drew this he built and tried to no no
I'm telling you that this is he watched
TV this is how you moved him he spent
his own money and and built a a uh like
a hologram yeah yeah kind of machine so
I got to listen to this cut to
2022
I sit on the board of a company called
Proto and it is run and and I've vested
in it and there are people from there's
ndas but I that they deal with um the
Kennedy Space Center every Bank
Christie's it's the high it's the newest
and latest in hologram it was based on
this episode This Moment really yeah and
and you've got to meet David you want to
meet David yeah sure okay David say hi
oh is he here on a hologram oh hey Mike
oh no is it going to start glitching no
how to actually make it work so thank
you I appreciate it you inspired all of
this but do you know in 3D over here oh
is that what this camera no that's not
this camera that's a real hologram and I
swear to you that these machines are in
the Saint Jude Hospital so people can
visit with their with their friends
these machines I've been doing concerts
like this live there's been big concerts
kiss is buying them Michael Buble has
them on the road oh my God you can be
anywhere you could be in Austin and
direct your but David was the guy
watching your show and created this
company based on a scene from Silicon
Valley and it's called Proto wait does
it make you look like Adam Sandler kind
of or is it true that's every Jew that's
every Jew
but you can put you can put stuff on you
can uh yeah you could that you can put
filters on him if you want to
wow that's that's really cool so uh yeah
I'm beaming into to thank you this is if
if not for that if not for that very
episode
um there's a good chance that none of
this happens we are in uh like 20
countries we've got hundreds of units
out there and we're beaming guys like
Howie and and and and and Diddy and uh
Walker Hayes Ellen we're beaming people
all over the place right now uh live
Hollow portation because of that scene
is this uh are you in one of these
things like these cylinder things right
no he's wherever he is but I mean as
he's inside no he just what's in front
of you just a nothing a camera camera
yeah yeah it looks really good yeah and
he can see you he can see us and there's
no latency this is real I know this is
really do you have to have some super
high bandwidth no you can do this with
your own uh phone you could do this on
on an iPhone you know and this is it is
amazing so David you inspire what is
considered a whole industry which is
probably and it's uh you know they've
they've raised tons millions and
millions and millions of dollars it's
all over Europe Asia everywhere because
of one scene that you wrote as a joke
for your hatred yeah technology well
this one works see Gavin belson's thing
didn't work they had to go they had to
go to the landline it is true I mean
from Office Space and Beavis and
Butthead and and all the Incredible
movies it was that scene in Silicon
Valley I said enough's enough you know
I've I've seen Hollow portation in The
Jetsons I've seen it in Back to the
Future I've seen it in Star Wars yeah
that scene though I said that is
realistic looking though that is the
first time I said wait a second we
should do that for real and here we are
um we're beaming people all over the
place now we had to use special effects
to make it look real and there's no
special effect he's actually here thanks
Dave well oh yeah thank you oh wow all
right thanks it's really good it looks
really amazing it is it is I'll show you
after we have we have a whole showroom
here audio is great too the audio is
great the the video is great and he is
actually here you can do I do concerts
and you know the people on on stage I
guess the people from Kiss were here and
they were talking about maybe having
Lenny Kravitz or Eddie Vedder live on
stage from real time they can come from
their house wow or do whatever thanks
Dave
see me later